[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an action thriller film
called unleashed spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the film we are
introduced to a vicious loan shark named
bart his way of collecting money from
the debtors is quite unique and ruthless
bart has been training a man named danny
as a dog for his entire life ever since
danny was little he has been locked in a
cage fed dog food and trained to obey
his mental capacity is that of a child
as he doesn't know how to speak or act
other than what is taught to him dany
has a special dog collar around his neck
at all times while he is wearing it he
is harmless but as soon as the caller
comes off he turns into an unleashed
aggressive dog and kills anyone who is
troubling his master bart is merciless
to dany he frequently beats and insults
him but since dany doesn't know any
better he thinks the abuse is a form of
affection one day after a long day of
beating people up for money bart brings
danny home a man notices that his
forehead is bleeding and hands him a
bandage but dany is so naive that he
doesn't understand the purpose of it he
simply goes back to his cage and starts
punching a bag he also has a first
grader's book that he uses to entertain
himself he learns a few new words and
shows great interest in learning the
following day they continue the routine
of threatening the debtors one of their
targets is a wealthy businessman who
owes bart a lot of money he is not like
the typical people they deal with
because he knows about the collar trick
to prevent bart from triggering dany
they pull bart away before he can take
the caller off they beat him up while
dany watches in confusion unsure what he
should do bart struggles and manages to
take his caller off in the end this
triggers the beast and dany and he
fights and finishes the enemies in no
time his unusual fighting skills don't
go unnoticed by a man standing nearby
his name is wyeth and he is the
organizer of an underground fight match
when he looks at dany he sees an
opportunity to earn a lot of money after
the debtor is beaten half to death bart
gets his money and comes outside
although danny saved his life the man is
furious that he didn't save him when he
was getting beaten he calls danny an
unworthy animal overlooking the fact
that he is the reason behind danny's
behavior for the last destination of the
day they stop at an antique warehouse to
be sure that the last trick won't be
repeated again bart asks danny to stay
in the warehouse while keeping a close
eye on an alarm when it glows red he is
asked to come inside and help danny and
his henchmen as dany waits he sees a
piano in a corner of the room he
remembers seeing it in the book and is
fascinated by it he presses a few keys
when a blind pianist comes into the room
his name is sam and he is here to tune
the piano upon seeing that danny is
interested in playing it sam helps him
it is a foreign experience for dany
because he hasn't been treated with
kindness ever in his life throughout the
interaction danny doesn't say anything
but sam doesn't seem to care to help him
focus he asks danny to listen to the
ticking sound of the clock this reminds
him of the alarm that his master had
told him to watch dany sees that it is
lit and rushes inside to find bart on
the floor completely beaten he and his
henchmen have managed to defeat the
enemies but were severely hurt in the
process they returned to their base and
yell at danny calling him different
names and kicking him into his cage then
wyeth comes to meet bart and offers a
business idea he wants dany to fight in
the next underground battle against the
current champion since the battle is a
death match that only ends when a person
dies the money is immense if dany is
able to beat the current champion bart
will earn a fortune so he doesn't waste
a second before accepting the deal the
following day danny is taken to the ring
the opponent has been in the game for
three years and has never been defeated
everyone bets on him confident about his
skills but when the match starts danny
lands three strong punches to his neck
and kills him in less than a minute
wyeth is overjoyed to have found such a
gem he hands bart his share of the money
promising to send more later on their
way back to the hideout the gangster is
in a good mood he urges dany to ask for
anything he wants danny vegley says
piano but bart sees no use of a musical
instrument to a dog suddenly their car
is hit by a truck the wealthy
businessman who was beaten up yesterday
has brought his people to kill bart they
fire at the vehicle repeatedly
eventually getting the gangster but dany
is left alive with only a single bullet
hitting him with his master gone he has
only one place to go the antique
warehouse he finds sam inside who
recognizes him by his footsteps danny
falls unconscious before he can ask for
help when he wakes up he is on the
fluffiest surface he has ever been on he
takes a second before realizing that he
is in a foreign room it turns out sam
brought him to his house and has been
taking care of him danny has been out
for two days straight so sam is happy to
finally have him back he is still unused
to being treated with kindness and the
new atmosphere makes him nervous sam's
stepdaughter victoria arrives at the
house and a scared dany hides under the
bed she realizes that he is special and
brings a keyboard under the bed asking
him to use it since he likes piano at
dinner the family waits for danny to
join them he comes outside clutching the
keyboard to himself because he has never
had food in front of people he starts
devouring it like he usually does
victoria stops him and teaches him how
to eat properly without making a mess
danny's eccentric behavior makes the
family laugh making him feel a certain
way that he has never felt later sam
tries taking his collar off which
startles dany he refuses to let anyone
touch it so sam doesn't force him the
following morning sam and dany drop
victoria at her college before
separating she kisses dany on the cheek
making him flustered he had read about a
kiss in his first grader book and is
happy to have experienced it in real
life sam notices this and smiles to
himself careful victoria that's
bestiality he also registers that dany
has gone through something bad in life
which has affected his mental capacity
to help him socialize sam brings him to
a grocery store and asks him to interact
with the cashier although nervous danny
watches sam talk to people in awe later
that day he is asked to bring victoria
home from college he nervously meets her
and the two go out for ice cream at
night victoria cannot sleep so she wakes
danny up and teaches him how to play the
basic keys on the piano sam hears them
from his bedroom and smiles that danny
is finally opening up to them in a short
time he becomes an inseparable part of
their lives one day danny and sam are at
the grocery store when some thugs start
a fight with each other sam and the
entire audience are scared but dany
continues judging the vegetables as if
nothing is happening behind him later
sam finds him and asks him how he was
calm in a situation like that danny
simply replies that they weren't
fighting him so he shouldn't interfere
sam is intrigued by the answer and
inquires about dany's past he finds out
that dany's innocence was used to make
him violent and sympathizes with him for
the next few weeks they live as a happy
family danny finally allows victoria to
take off his collar and is calm without
it as well then one day sam takes him to
work to fix a piano while working on the
instrument he reveals that he and
victoria are moving back to new york
after she graduates danny is heartbroken
because that would mean he will be left
without a family again but sim clarifies
that they're taking him as well since he
is a part of the family now after work
danny is given half of the money because
he helped sam he excitedly goes to the
store to buy a gift for everyone but on
his way out he bumps into a guy who used
to work for bart he reveals that bart is
still alive and is looking for danny
everywhere since he is his main source
of income danny agrees to come because
he wants to know who his parents are in
the following scene dany meets bart and
inquires about his mother bart replies
that he found danny on the side of the
road and never bothered to look for his
parents after that danny is taken to yet
another death match his boss makes him
wear the collar and then takes it off
only to find out that the trick doesn't
work anymore when dany refuses to kill
anyone he is pushed into the battle ring
with a dangerous opponent he proceeds to
hit dany but he doesn't retaliate to
make the match interesting more fighters
are put into the ring but even upon
being abused brutally dany doesn't fight
back all of a sudden after a man steps
on his hand something in dany's brain
clicks he turns into his former self and
it doesn't take long for him to defeat
all of his opponents at the end of the
day dany is beaten and thrown into his
cage again somewhere else victoria and
sam are worried about him but have no
clue where to look for him when no one
is around dany breaks out of the cage
and finds a bunch of pictures on bart's
workstation he recognizes himself in a
picture where he is sitting with his
mother in front of the piano he attacks
bart and asks him about his mother for
the last time the man reveals that she
was an adult worker who used to be his
escort for many nights she even brought
little danny to work and had no regard
for boundaries but bart fell in love
with her so when she died of a disease
he took dany in and made him his family
the following day they are driving to
work when dany hears the word family
which reminds him of sam and victoria he
swerves the car causing it to crash and
taking the opportunity to run away
following that he returns to his real
family who are over the moon to finally
see him upon finding out the story about
his mother they feel bad for him
victoria describes the background of the
picture and sam recognizes it as an
auditorium that he has been to to find
out more about danny's mother they go to
the auditorium the staff there recognize
her but claim that she disappeared with
her son one day and never returned
victoria finds a music note in the
picture's background and uses it to play
the piano the tune is the one that
danny's mother used to play when he was
little this brings back the memories he
had suppressed over the years a
flashback then shows us that his mother
was a musician with no money hence she
took a loan from bart in exchange for
her body she always kept danny away from
the business until one day bart found
out about him when she refused to let
him see the kid she was killed and danny
was kidnapped after regaining the
memories dany realizes how dangerous
bart is he tries to make salmon victoria
pack their bags to leave the city
instantly but before they leave bart and
a large gang of his men arrive at sam's
apartment building danny hides sam and
victoria in their closet for their
safety before running out to distract
the thugs he faces off against a man
named the stranger he is an attacker
hired by bart with a skill level similar
to his own they get into an intense
battle which ends when the stranger
falls out of the window while dany does
his best to save him in the end bart
pursues danny and finds out which
apartment he used to live in he
threatens to kill sam and veronica if he
doesn't come outside danny has to
reluctantly give up to save his loved
ones but when he gets close enough to
bart he attacks him and furiously beats
him sam and victoria burst out of the
closet to stop him knowing that he isn't
a killer when everything calms down the
three embrace each other at the same
time the police arrive and arrest bart
for the plethora of crimes he has
committed in the last scene danny and
sam attend a piano recital where
victoria is performing she says the
piece is dedicated to a special person
and performs the song that danny's
mother played years ago danny watches
her in awe and sheds a happy tear
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching